in the lobby of financial peace Plaza
its Andean Calais hey hey guys how are
you awesome how are you welcome better
than I deserve where do you guys live in
Atlanta alright it's fun and you're in
Nashville today I assume standing in our
lobby and Martha's place to do your debt
free scream yeah free but I like it how
much have you paid off total one hundred
twenty three thousand dollars phenomenal
how long did that date it took us five
years and we also cash flowed $50,000
worth of home improvements Wow okay okay
cool and making what kind of money
during this time we started at about
ninety what we were both working and
then we went down to about fifty when I
stayed home with the kids
we probably averaged around 60 or so
during that time gotcha okay what kind
of debt was the hundred and twenty three
thousand it was all mortgage oh you paid
for house this is awesome how old are
you I'm 31
yeah we our goal is to paid off by my
30th birthday but we missed it by 12
hours but we'll take it
close enough yeah I think we count that
one good okay I think that comes in
under the wire there we'll call that
inbounds an inbound catch way to go so
what's the house worth Oh probably
around 200 or so that's pretty neat
you're 30 years old you have a paid-for
house how weird are you be super weird
that is so fun a paid-for house in
Atlanta Georgia
you guys are neat so what happened five
years ago that made you decide that this
could happen and that you wanted to do
it well we actually found your radio
show about eight years ago it was about
a month after we got married we hadn't
even gotten our first grown-up paycheck
yet and we decided right away to start
living on one income and we used my
income to pay off our student loans and
then to start saving for a down payment
for the house so when we bought the
house about five years ago it was with
the intention to pay it off as quickly
as we could and took us about five years
with cash flowing the improvements
because we bought a gross old
foreclosure and we've been fixing it up
one project at a time and so so really I
mean over five years you've basically
done a hundred and seventy five thousand
dollars worth of stuff here yeah that
reduction and improvements on the
foreclosure
lutely yep absolutely amazing how does
this feel I mean this is weird they
don't have a house payment
it feels so free and not just that but
every step along the way has been
increasing freedom when we first sat
down and made our written budget and we
had control over our money we felt freer
and and then once we were debt-free
except for our house we felt it even
more actually two years after we bought
our house I got laid off from my job and
because we didn't have any debt except
for the house we were free to have me
now stay home with the kids and as a
result of that I started blogging and I
was writing about how we were fixing up
our house on a tiny budget sharing tips
and tutorials for other people to do it
along the way and it became a full-time
job totally my dream job I can't believe
it happened and now Andy has the
business supporting bloggers and so
becoming debt-free has really gotten
into every corner of our life and it's
changed everything and we're just so
grateful very cool so how are you
monetizing your blog well I have ads but
today actually have a sponsored post by
you Dave about how we paid off our
mortgage and about our experience using
the e L piece oh very cool yeah but
revenue and things like that
very neat okay I didn't realize you were
connected with us in that way that's
awesome yeah my post went up today
that's fine yeah very very cool
well we'll have to get you to a blog
about the new book kids smart money
smart kids book that Rachel and I are
doing yeah we're excited to read that
because we have two little ones and you
know we grew up in that and that kind of
thing those kind of puzzles and so we
really want to read and research how to
you know grow our kids the right way
well cattle make sure you leave with one
of the promotional galleys that are back
which is the book in advance for media
and your media so we'll take you way to
go man you guys are awesome how
entrepreneurial and smart and 30 years
old and a paid-for house and did I
mention that your house is paid for by
your birthday this is wacky I love you
guys yeah God has been good to us he
really has I mean what do people say
when you tell them this do you tell many
people that are close to you today's the
day that we kind of unleashed on the
blog and came out of a debt free closet
today oh yeah we did and we're a little
bit nervous but everyone's been so
supportive and they think that we're
really weird and we are
right you are you are weird in such a
good way absolutely amazing and so
you've had friends and family that were
supportive did anybody make fun of you
along the way
oh for sure I mean we we've just made
weird decisions every step of the way I
mean we're crazy coupon people and we've
drove driven really crappy cars and II
drove a tiny purple Ford Escort that was
like 10 years old and oh god I hope you
have a picture of that we do yes we do
Oh send us a picture of that I love it I
can't think of my anything much worse
than a tiny Ford purple as we called it
the great that's like the bottom of the
beater barrel it's pretty bad yeah well
just a violent terror in the great lease
Ark right and you make sure the kids get
this stuff right that they know that mom
and dad paid a price that's the goal and
that this one didn't just happen it's
not accidental it wasn't just somebody
handed you this you you made different
decisions than your friends and your
peers and it puts you in a different
place than your friends and peers and so
you ought to be proud you ought to be
very proud we're proud of you I'll tell
you that it's absolutely awesome all
right Andy and Kelly from Atlanta
Georgia where's the kids do they realize
they're being read to being read to they
got to do the debt-free chef they do
practicing practicing my little girl our
little girl is 20 months old and she's
been yelling 1 2 okay gotta practice all
the way from Atlanta then we got to do
this right Andy and Kelly from Atlanta
Georgia just 30 years old 123 thousand
dollars paid off house and everything in
five years making 90 now down to fifty
sixty thousand dollars a year count it
down let's hear a debt free scream maybe
one two three
very very very well done I love it I'm
so proud of you beautiful beautiful
stuff
you